part this story we got here from
timcast.com Gates McCarthy reportedly
texted Republican who voted against him
quote I am ready to fund an endless war
not the first thing I think when I see
that is come on man no way like that's
such a that's such a like I hereby
announce I am guilty kind of statement
you know what I mean
McCarthy apparently said here look at uh
gate said
McCarthy is losing it he texted one of
my colleagues who didn't vote for him
quote I am ready to fund an endless war
I'm assuming this is an addition to
Ukraine
but I wonder if what McCarthy was
basically saying was I'm so pissed off
at these people you know what I mean
yeah like they want to come at me I'm
ready to find an endless war because
these people oppose it isn't that what
they already have been doing for for
example since 2001 before that and uh
the war machine hasn't really uh stopped
it's been getting financed a lot a lot
of money has been printed a lot of money
has been devalued in order to fill up
the coffers of the military industrial
complex so uh his threat is kind of
empty there because they're already
doing it you know what I love too
apparently when uh bobert Gates and the
rest were like leaving the meeting like
recently they came out I can't remember
who said bobert that opposition to
McCarthy actually increased and that's
what I love to hear my attitude is like
if you come to me and I say all right
look I'll vote for you hear the things
that I that I need and you say no I'll
say I want to vote for you then if you
threaten me I'll be like well now I'm
gonna go Advocate people vote against
you then you threaten me again I'll be
like I'm gonna do everything in my power
to make sure you don't win I think
that's where Matt Gates is basically at
like
McCarthy spits in his face you know what
I mean could Matt Gates run or could
someone nominate him yeah but no it has
I don't know I think the point is that
he's saying it's like it's a matter of
principle it's not about him it's about
getting rid of McCarthy you know this is
one of the most promising things but let
me let me show you this uh this tweet
from Charlie Kirk rep Rokon he's a
Democrat says he's open to a coalition
government with the right Republican as
Speaker with two conditions no
government shutdowns over debt ceiling
limiting subpoena power of the GOP there
it is
what are the chances that happens that I
actually think might happen
they go to Kevin McCarthy and they say
we will get you the five votes that you
need to win
but no subpoena power for the GOP and
McCarthy will say deal
well no investigations no accountability
yeah trading that's like uh bribe is
that a form of bribery it's what they do
all day every day in Congress it's
called politics it's also interesting to
see AOC
um kind of meet with a lot of the
Republican leadership
um there's been a lot of conversations
that they've been having that they've
been documented having and a lot of
people are talking about a proposal that
the two might actually come to an
agreement with and it's pretty much
compromises and Kevin McCarthy is really
good on compromises but uh the base
hates the compromises because I think
it's fair to say that the Republicans
have compromised a lot the Democrats
don't really compromise that much they
really they really essentially get to
their way and the Republicans kind of
back them off just just a little bit
just enough just to make a little
difference just so they look a little
different but in reality I I think it's
plausible I think there's a possibility
that Kevin McCarthy could make a deal
with the Democrats in a way that could
of course benefit the establishment and
uh good so what
that's my attitude so what make them
show you who they are make Kevin
McCarthy show you that he is with the
Democrats there you go most people think
he already is but make him show every
single person just just just get that
because there's no point in just giving
in I'm seeing so many people be like oh
no Kevin McCarthy doesn't win you're
gonna get a never Trumper or a Democrat
and I'm like isn't Kevin McCarthy a
never Trump or Democrat like I I don't
know the difference between what he
represents and what like he was he was
nominated by Liz Cheney
okay I'm I just do I don't see it I
really don't he's gonna he's he's been
pandering for the past couple of months
but apparently the freedom caucus people
proposed made proposals that were not
unreasonable and he was just like no I
don't need your votes and then
apparently they've come to him and asked
for concessions and he's like no and now
now apparently the talking point is
that he's claiming that or or what
they're claiming is Gates and others
wanted guarantees to be on committees or
something like that and I'm just like I
don't care I don't like heaven McCarthy
there's no reason for me to ever support
anybody like him I just don't care so
I'm gonna sit back and I'm gonna laugh
every time he loses now going on six
losses going at seven seven coming up
soon right now there you go he's gonna
have to go to the Democrats and beg and
then I want the entire the entirety of
the old school Republican party to be
like why is he negotiating with
Democrats
um see how he does yeah otherwise
what happens you think that Kevin
McCarthy is actually going to empower
any people any of these people to do
anything legitimate I'm surprised people
are actually saying that you think
there's any hope for like I mean now
that I know who Ron Paul is I know who
Rand Paul is but there's any hope for
like um you know these these
Independents these green these these
dissenters like in my opinion where we
are now it's 100 grown the fact that I'm
here and we're all here and we're
chatting like none of us in my I don't
know who your history is but we don't
seem radical in any direction and the
fact that that has grown it's never
existed you know before it was like what
all I remember is Ralph Nader that's the
only person I remember my whole life
growing up that's the only name that
rung a bell for green party
um 29. there's Ross Perot so I don't
know I don't know he ran against Bill
Clinton okay 92 and they say that he
split the vote allowing Bill Clinton to
win that basically it was it was Bush
Perot and Clinton and then you got
moderates and Republicans split between
Perot and Bush so it's been a
significant enough percentage yeah let
me tell you something I need to have
like a big no there's Jim Carrey but I
think he was like an economist what was
the percentage of this specific I don't
know you want to pull it up yeah I'm
curious um you only need like one
percent right to make an impact yep for
sure and so what I heard was that he was
a business guy and he was attractive to
politically to more modern individuals
and then Clinton wins he won over 19.7
million votes for 18.9 share of the
popular vote wow and then apparently
George Bush Senior lost and they blamed
that and then what was the other
percentage what was it let me see if I
can I have to look into that
this is the most significant green 1992
right yeah this is 92. so that's when I
was born you said you were 29 so we're
only three yeah yeah we're like this is
the most significant green party vote of
all time this guy or no you have no idea
is the most significant green party vote
uh Ross Perot he ran independent just so
this is the most significant independent
party yeah yeah Teddy Roosevelt won as
an independent in 19. I don't even know
that 08 or something
was what he called it yeah here it is 43
for Bill Clinton if if Perot did not win
I I don't think Clinton could have won I
don't think he would have he may he
probably would have done better because
obviously some Democrats did vote for
Perot but Perot likely it was it was was
as an independent got more Republicans
but I'm looking at the electoral votes
which really is all the matter the
popular vote's not really relevant you
think Independence that's true I know
it's not a conspiracy uh you know driven
no but but it's not but think about this
in uh let's grab a random State let's
say uh uh I don't know Iowa right Bill
Clinton wins because George W bush
didn't get enough vote right in Iowa
because Ross Perot got a portion of it
so it matters so does you know do
Democrats send in a Ross Pro in these
scenario like does that exist is that
possible it's not of course the Trump
was their Pied Piper candidate they said
in 2016 that you know support Pied Piper
candidates like Donald Trump and others
so that people go and support them and
they can't win and then Trump won and I
think that's one of the reasons Hillary
was so mad she's the one who was trying
to prop him up right they tried the same
strategy again in 2020 and it like half
worked right they were they were the
Democrats were funding the messaging of
trump Republicans hoping that it would
it would it would spike the election and
force Democrats to win yeah
well it maybe worked in some place I
think ballot harvesting was the real
trick like I'm friends uh you know spy
Cohen is or no yeah so he's been on the
show okay I didn't know that so I'm
friendly with Spike Cohen and like like
perfect example like he's not he's not
some agent sent in to take away votes
from whatever but like historically it's
totally possible to be like hey like we
know you're not gonna win and we know
you're more conservative and like you
know people leaning right are more on
the fence left they don't really care so
we're gonna pull away votes from one
party significantly that's possible 100
I think it's probably why they don't
really don't give media attention to a
lot of third fourth fifth party
candidates I don't like saying third
party candidates because that only
implies there's only gonna be three
there's should be lots and lots of
political parties but I think there
there are lots of the media is afraid
that if new candidates get in that stuff
will get all split up and you'll have
another Abraham Lincoln they're always
leaning a certain way you know what I
mean me and my fiance we always talk
about like like you could be libertarian
like which is what I always like I
always call myself that and she's like
you're just scared to call yourself
conservative but in general my point is
is like someone leans a certain way like
a Libertarian leads left or they're with
someone who leans right So eventually
someone's gonna someone's gonna pick
when it comes to a certain topic no
matter what they're going to be more
liberal or more conservative there's no
such thing as I'm more of the middle you
pick on every single subject even if you
are more than being more of my opinion
being more of the middle is you are a la
carte you're not just like an
establishment person who votes
regardless no matter what you're like
hey I think this with abortion and this
with 2A and this with blah blah and
that's how most people at this table are
is like hey like we pick a la carte like
what makes sense versus like I was told
I have to vote this way every single
time no matter what you know what I mean
so it's like we talked about the value
of taking r d off the tickets so you
don't know what party you're voting for
yeah they said the same thing then you'd
be voting for names and people change
their name right Buzz Lightyear this
lightning storm and stuff of course John
Democrat yeah someone in when we now
decide this is what they like let's put
someone here so you're right I mean that
strategy would still work right now
right it's just not easy to change your
name it actually is quite difficult
maybe you could say I was watching uh
Nathan for you you guys ever watched
Nathan he did that thing where it's like
he was trying to get a guy to change his
name and you have to like announce it in
newspaper for three weeks so he made a
fake newspaper it was actually pretty it
was pretty clever I guess it worked you
know but it's not easy to change your
name you could do that and then just
force them to use their name from back
in the day but then you get into dead
naming and I don't know how that
culturally plays these days Ross Pro ran
again in 96 he got eight percent of the
vote and Bob Dole lost Bob Dole I loved
Ross bro I really wanted Ross Perot he
seemed like he was going to do good
stuff for the US I don't know I was a
kid I was like 12 when he ran but okay
it was definitely it was nice to see
someone talk about something other than
politics and like um he was like if you
can look at the economy and he pulled
these charts while he was campaigning
and like show people economics and stuff
it's really really nice and this is the
first time I heard this name man um
whether I'm young or just an idiot I
don't know politics too much but that's
that's I would uh he had Ross Pro you
got my vote yeah Ross apparently you're
going to 2000 where Al Gore actually won
the popular vote lost the Electoral
College that was a wild election year
you guys obviously seen the Al Gore
South Park so that was like and then
oh man bear pig man bear pig that was
the extent of my College of Al Gore
because I was so young this is 2000
everything was George Bush 911 Ira like
I was a young kid I'm like 10 not even
eight and like the all my extent was
like South Park Al Gore that was yeah I
gotta say I just jumped to 2016. this is
actually hilarious Hillary Clinton got
three million more votes than Trump and
lost
too bad too bad lady thank God it's a
republic Trump got I think something
like 77 000 votes spread across three
states which got more enough electoral
votes to win correct me if I'm wrong
this is allegedly the next ticket
potentially like people are saying this
Hillary Clinton people are saying this
is like extremely plausible it's this I
don't think so what Michelle Obama I
don't know who then who yeah I mean it's
a good point Democrats don't have
anybody but I don't even think Trump's
going to do it to be honest do you think
it'll be DeSantis versus Michelle Obama
yeah maybe maybe
I think Trump will go here's my
prediction and uh please please bet
against me because I'm probably wrong
but I'm just saying I think there's a
decent probability what we end up seeing
is Trump goes in the primary Trump
narrowly loses the primary but then
claps and cheers and says that Santa is
going to do a good job I'm going to get
behind him and that's how Trump is
winding things down because the things
he's done have been very very weak as of
late I am not convinced Trump is serious
look at Trump 2016. calling Rosie
O'Donnell a fat pig or whatever yeah
he's not doing any of that and even as
most Ardent supporters said that his
announcement speech was very weak but
his his endorsement whoever he endorses
is going to make a huge huge impact on
the election no matter what maybe I kind
of like the idea that he runs against
DeSantis and then graciously says
DeSantis is the guy and then he has he
becomes a hero like a lore hero with his
fan base everyone wants that everyone
wants like first of all a ticket
together is never going to happen I
imagine every every Republican wants a
trump to send his ticket I don't think
it's hot that's like a ridiculous ticket
it's guaranteed it's not
you guys don't understand like yeah I've
seen what Trump's been up to within the
last few years there's no way here's
what's going to happen there's a lot of
ego there I don't see it Trump's going
to start campaigning very heavily and
then just in the in early 2024 and the
full swing of things
or I should say whatever whatever point
right before the RNC when is it what is
rnc's uh summer of 24. trump will be
walking down the street with some
reporters when all of a sudden he hears
yyping and yelping and there's a burning
building and he says I hear puppies and
he's going to run in and then he's going
to run out covered in Smoke and singed
carrying a box of puppies he's going to
put him down and say you're safe little
ones but I am too injured to run for
president at this point I must but I
have no choice to endorse Rhonda Sanders
because saving puppies had my sacrifice
so that's that's a good um something
like do you think his VP Choice can can
change your mind to him or anyone's mind
listening who maybe agrees you guys are
drinking a lot of Kool-Aid I just want
to say this for a fact I'm serious no
who's you guys we have opposing opinions
right I think Trump will run and I think
that and I think he potentially could
win depending on his VP candid I think
people bring up Tulsi gabbard they bring
up a million possibilities I know it's
forget who I just said my point is like
that VP candidate can totally change an
election I'm not I'm not completely I'm
not saying like I'm at this point maybe
like 80 20 80 DeSantis 20 Trump there
was a period you know I'm back and forth
earlier in the year last year I was like
maybe DeSantis then I saw Trump want to
fire everybody and I was like I'm
leaning more Trump then people like uh
Carl Benjamin from Lotus Eaters was like
Trump's got to finish his narrative Arc
he's got to get back in and then I was
like okay I like that and then people
were like and then you get to send us an
opportunity for for you know eight more
years or whatever which is hardly what
I've heard yeah maybe maybe not likely
it's like that's crazy thing to think 12
years of Republicans or whatever but now
we're at the point where like
you know Trump is endorsing McCarthy for
one thing Trump is is selling nfts and
I'm like this is not this this guy look
in 2016 and 20 he was serious right he's
not serious anymore I think I think he's
an old man
and I mean that with all due respect I
think he's just thinking to himself I
have fought a very very hard fight
and now I just don't think it's there
anymore his daughter's out he has a
history though of of getting in a lot of
swamp monsters so this is not his first
swamp monster that he endorsed so this
is not odd this is not you know totally
different Trump here this is the same
Trump that that put of course John
Bolton in power that put fauci in power
that wanted Bill Gates as a science
advisor so this is not out of the norm
so it's not like oh no he's doing he
being he literally changed like
obviously I love what the Sanders did
for I think the only reason the sand has
got any sort of Base aside from Trump
you know endorsing and saying hey he's a
good guy was coveted and the way he
handled Florida and like like life was
good in Florida and when I would go to
DC they called police on me for eating
at a restaurant like like it was
drastically different in every state but
um you guys have heard everything what's
your opinion on the possibility that um
DeSantis is similar to a bush is that
possible is that possible at all it's
impossible like he's a Warhol it's not
yeah is that possible impossible I would
say is is it likely no
but it's not it's not yes or no it's not
black or white right DeSantis will
probably do some things that will piss
people off but I think he's already
shown he's done a lot of things that
have really really inspired people and
he's been he's been commended for so his
his he has done so well in Florida that
Florida has like the highest rate of of
immigration into the state right 100
California's being drained right I don't
like judging the guy before I know him
but what but what about you Luke judge
him for me what do you think about Ron
DeSantis do you think he's a Warhawk uh
you you you have to be critical of
everyone
um you you never you never put all your
eggs in one basket you never prop up any
man above yourself uh that's number one
so never give any politician a benefit
of the doubt so let him prove himself
let's see what he does let's see what he
says let's ask him some real questions
uh there are some bad people surrounding
him which we should be critical of uh
but he's in his he's in the dialogue
he's making big moves that of course are
making uh National discussions
especially among smokness especially
what's happening in schools especially
what's happening with the vaccines those
conversations wouldn't happen if it
wasn't for him so therefore overall
those conversations are good and then
that positive do you think Donald Trump
is not being a part of the conversations
he is selling nfts and he's not on
Twitter we had an argument here on this
show before I was like Trump's not going
to be on Twitter you guys are screaming
at me like he's going to be on Twitter
I'm like no he's not that's not what I
said I said he has to be on he has to
but I I said he there's a big chance he
won't sure sure and he hasn't been and
that's why another reason I think he's
retiring he is not getting back into the
frame I mean if he was retiring he
wouldn't have been running to be
president of the United that's not true
I I just don't can't he can't just stop
he's got to wind things down he's got to
work out deals with the intelligence
agencies up to the right of this house
he has to negotiate something and that
is a transfer of power yeah I was just
looking at my copy of Art of War last
night thinking about Donald Trump like
he's all about business dealings lying
and then doing what you don't expect and
all that stuff he's really good so he
might he might pull uh I'm running and
then nobody
the primary he generates a ton of
attention and then directs that energy
in somewhere else or endorsing Kevin
McCarthy to me as an indicator that the
Deep State went to him and said on your
knees or we come after your family and
he said please please spare me oh I mean
it could have been the same thing
without you could have been the same
thing with exactly with that war
criminal what's his name
um John Bolton so they raided his house
and he probably went please please I
just wanted to stop and they said then
endorse that then endorse the Deep State
he says anything you say master ooh
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time